I lost a lot a love of my life the
mother of my children the one with whom
I should have been all my life she was
suffering from mental disorder
schizophrenia manic depression and
nobody could help her she went away
I was broken inside but I had no time
nor to heal nor to sit there with my
grief because I had four children very
little money left behind and there are
the challenges came and when the
challenges came then television came and
television is crazy because they begin
to challenge you so when they challenge
me I could do everything
I got 26 World Records but numerous more
challenges done and they are all a led
to the extremes of water mind and a body
is able to do even past what in science
was thought possible they gave me a cold
water upon the skin I could do nothing
just use my mind and I made the skin
temperature not going down that is the
power of the mind making having physical
consequences in the body to defy stress
coming in just using the mind this was
unknown in Psychiatry if I would have
had that knowledge back then with my
wife then I could have treated her
naturally but I had no power then but I
pledged my
oath to my wife if I'm able to get out
of this grief to get out of where you
have been then I will show the world and
all the people who are suffering
mentally I will be able to pass on a
natural way of how to get out of your
grief how to bring your a spouse or
husband out of there and be a good
parent love is the greatest power of the
universe and that we lost a tribal sense
of helping each other and so all the
problems in the world we have a system
inside in willful possible command if we
only exercise and awaken to it to handle
anything that comes to us because that's
the way we were built not hopeless full
of Hope and not 20 of the brain capacity
within our Command but hundred
and there it is and with 100 we find
Freedom because we can go anywhere
without fear because we are in control
the understanding of the viewer of The
Listener that we are built with the
capacity to neurologically grow into our
brain and grow grow like like excited a
children
that that is the feeling of life should
be instead of depression for God's sake
depression what is that it is a big
problem and it's a and we got so much
technology how poor we are in our the
quality of our own life we go to the
Moon we go to Mars but we don't know how
to stop out immune diseases cancer
depression and name it and more and more
angsta anxiety fear for death fear what
is the soul it's still unknown and I
tell you it is the time for the soul we
think we can handle our physiology my
conviction is once again we are meant to
be able to tap in any time into our
system to make us happy strong healthy
your purpose if you get into the DNA
into the encrypted quotes damaged by
trauma of your ancestors who passed on
in Generations their trauma in the
genetics
then you feel relieved you feel
enlightened
so if we go for the best within
ourselves
for a freedom a failed state of being a
very powerful being that is not being
withhold without by anything if you like
that then you have to go and deal with
the encrypted codes in the DNA and
release it not if being profane and
shallow but going into the depth if you
look deeply within yourself and find out
why you are here
what follow and that you have a great
impact possible by standing up and do
things out of the box and do it be
audacious have no fear children know
they are naturally still at the core we
got alienated they are still there they
are born with it we should never go away
because that unconditional love
unconditional power to be healthy strong
and health and happy doesn't need six
cars or ten houses no it's already there
and with that we don't we go away from
this possessive way of thinking and and
insensitive trying to find a position to
secure our life and all that fear-based
no you have the full control of your own
mind we were born with it and we never
are going to teach our children again to
become narrate in their Consciousness
but learned from the beginning to expand
to it all and that's the real School of
Life and wherein this soul is a flower
and it's amazing the love is stronger
than the mind so don't mind learn to
love life like you love love once you
get a hold of that you learn to activate
those Powers you learn to be better than
the food you learn to create energy you
learn to be stronger in the fight you
learn to not freeze but to express
yourself you learn that the the the the
the creative power with the pro
celebrating the love with the with your
person your sexual partner to have
children or to experience love you can
do that with life itself and this is
what happens you learn to tap into the
feeling pure feeling without label it's
like a poetry you you dance and and
there's this big and there it is no that
is the passion it's not just words it's
not an ABC it it the words come but the
feeling is the driving force and it's
inside giving testimonial of the beauty
of life itself in all its unlimitless
the brain itself the mind the seed of
the mind and the unlimited power of the
mind it all gets to us we become like
children again and I'm 62 but I am a
child of God of being here right now and
I love it because I love life I
challenge it every day I have no
boundaries and I'm going to change the
world this is where we got with our
extension tools our measurement devices
microscopes and all those things we
learned to take that as the truth
so I go through the truth through what
we think is the truth because we left
our simple uh belief in our the power of
our mind just to create happiness
strength and health and guarantee it for
our children no we had to take the land
and more and more and produce and more
and more and go to the moon man this
world is beautiful make up this world a
beautiful place instead of the pollution
that is existent right now and
exploitation and insensitivity we have
to stop this that is craziness the world
is sick the world needs to stop and to
begin to see that we are simple
beautiful beings with the power of
intention and it's called love to
guarantee love
composed by happiness strength and
health and are confident guarantee that
we are able to stand for that and to
give that to our children we have to go
back to the inner nature the way Nature
has meant it to be
we alienated there from and now we got
to go back that means going back to love
strength health and happiness
that's my story